what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we're going to
be talking about something that i know
fans are really anxious for and that is
wolverine in the mcu kind of a cool
little thing happened recently the
writers for deadpool 3 have kind of
talked about what they expect from
marvel studios and their wolverine
casting and this is pretty interesting
because ryan reynolds of course plays
deadpool him and hugh jackman are
insanely close now there's never been a
true deadpool solo film with wolverine
in it even though they make a ton of
references to wolverine and we're not
gonna really talk about x-men origins
wolverine even in the credit for
deadpool 2 ryan reynolds goes back in
time and kind of kills that character
but this is kind of cool because
deadpool 3 is going to be in the mcu
everybody's over at marvel studios now
including these writers so technically
this is kind of coming from marvel
studios not from kevin feige or any
executive producer but take a listen to
what they want from a future wolverine
in the mcu also quick side note all of
this talk about wolverine recently is
making me believe that at san diego
comic con and d23 we might get a mention
of the mutant
x-men in the mcu after all kevin feige
did mention the x-men at san diego comic
con in 2019 we are long overdue for an
update and apparently some big news is
supposed to drop at sdcc and d23 so
hopefully some of it at least is about
the mutants but the deadpool 3 writers
have casting ideas for wolverine and i
gotta say i agree with them and i think
a lot of fans will as well and it's also
kind of funny at the same time speaking
to the post credit podcast rhett reese
writer for deadpool 3 has talked about
the qualities he would like to see from
the mcu's wolverine and here's what he
said suggestions it's gotta be someone
shorter this time so maybe a zack
gilifinakis or patton oswalt someone
like that i don't know now he says that
and it's obviously just a joke i don't
think he really wants zach ilifinakis or
patton oswald to play wolverine no
offense to them but rhett reese does go
on to say some pretty good information
he says look we don't have any inside
information on that even if we did we
couldn't share it but we don't i would
honestly go more an undiscovered person
because hugh jackman was reasonably
undiscovered the first time and i think
there was an initial buck off oh he's
too tall or he doesn't look right or
what is this australian thing i think
that if they're playing their cards
right they probably should make it
someone we've never seen and that's a
pretty interesting suggestion i like
that idea because it's true when hugh
jackman became wolverine he wasn't that
well known at the time he's done some
amazing movies throughout his career but
the x-men movies were pretty big i mean
he is wolverine he is known for being
wolverine and the other writer for
deadpool 3 paul warnock stepped in and
said oh don't worry they'll play their
cards right you know kevin feige he
knows what he's doing over there he
doesn't need any of our opinions now i
love this because keep in mind kevin
feige was working with marvel and worked
on the x-men films that's how he got
started with marvel and there have been
a lot of fan castings for wolverine
lately and a lot of them are really
really good not patton oswalt good but
pretty dang good but i agree with the
writers i think wolverine needs to be
shorter in the comics he is five foot
three he is very short and he's 300
pounds but keep in mind most of that
weight is from the adamantium even
though wolverine is always pretty dang
jacked and that's one of the main
complaints of hugh jackman's wolverine
is he is way too tall to be wolverine
now don't get me wrong i love him as
wolverine he did an amazing job and
whoever the new wolverine is going to be
has some serious big shoes to fill but
since we're essentially rebooting let's
get somebody that is more comic accurate
somebody that deadpool could definitely
make fun of for being short and not
being who jackman because you know he's
gonna crack that joke but let me know
your thoughts on this i thought this was
really cool to hear from the deadpool 3
writers hopefully they put some jokes in
there but who would you like to see play
wolverine let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all of the latest
marvel news you can also follow me on
twitter and instagram for live updates
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof